it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases telltale is back doing
what they do best with Batman's the
tell-tale series the first of five
episodes puts us Batman aka Bruce Wayne
making decisions for both of those egos
its standard telltale here you get
decisions with time limits and QuickTime
events to progress the story but this
game also offers crowd play now this is
where the main player can provide the
audience with a link and then they can
work on the decisions together it sounds
pretty cool but your main villain in
this isn't the Joker it's latency if you
want to stream this most of your
decisions will be timed out by the time
your audience sees them so it might be
more of a land party thing anyway realm
of the shadows releases on everything on
the second Abdul is something unique a
stylized swimming simulator where you're
swimming around a massive body of water
with a bunch of various aquatic animals
this game is made by the aptly titled
studio giant squid which was founded by
the flower and journey art director so
you know you're in for a pretty stunning
visual experience now the game is linear
it's not open world but there's a ton of
different areas to explore in that sea
like caverns and deep oceanic areas
coral reefs and flooded ruins all with
fish that actually eat each other and
function like you know like fish do you
get to swim with the fishes on the
second if you're gonna have some friends
over you might want to check out
overcooked a couch co-op cooking game
for up to four players working as a team
you and your fellow chefs must prepare
cook and serve up a variety of tasty
orders before the customers get all mad
and stuff you'll be cooking in all sorts
of wacky kitchens yelling at your sous
chef for burning the butter like
whatever but with the right people this
looks like it could actually be a lot of
fun overcooked ends up on console and PC
on the third
finally tricky towers is a physics-based
our building game with tetra monoprix no
no no it's not just Tetris you have to
build a tower higher faster and better
than your opponents and yeah it kind of
does seem like Tetris and maybe like
Jenga going on together there but you
also get to cast magic spells to either
stabilize your own tower or sabotage
those other players when your tower
sways you better stabilize it with more
blocks maybe some magic lest your tower
fall to your opponent's tricky towers is
free for PS Plus subscribers so you're
going to want to grab that for ps4 on
the second and that's all I have for you
this week do you remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings
sometimes they change and I'll see you
guys again next week